noël en forme de clin d'oeil alors que
les magasins débordent de jouets des
peluches aux ordinateurs j'en passe et
des meilleurs nous allons vous présenter
ce soir les jouets auxquelles vous avez
échappé leur inventeur est un
collectionneur anglais qui chaque année
propose ses services au numéro un
mondial des fabricants
apparemment personne n'est sensible à
son talent sauf nous reportage de pascal
deschamps et andré saura
encore raté une fois de plus team est
obligé de tout remballer ses joies son
drôle mais le problème c'est que ces
jouets coûterait très cher à produire et
qu'il risque de sembler très futile à
l'acheteur potentiel c'est-à-dire la
mère des enfants
pour l'inventeur jouer qui marche c'est
le pactole alors tim parcourt le monde
pour trouver des idées il possède plus
de 4500 jouets qui ne reste pas dans ses
tiroirs je les balades pour animer des
goûters d'anniversaire j'en fais 50 par
an à peu près 1 par semaine je vais
aussi dans les clubs les hôpitaux les
crèches les maternelles est de plus en
plus depuis cinq ans je vais voir les
professionnels dans les entreprises j'ai
de bons rapports
vous savez il arrive à faire des jouets
étonnant pour parvenir à les convaincre
tim rouette multiplie les expériences
comme gonfler un ballon avec son
aspirateur
quelle recette pour la plus grosse bulle
de savon du monde tout son salaire
d'employés des british telecom y passe
mais il espère bien devenir milliardaire
en attendant comme vous n'avez aucune
chance de trouver s'est joué dans le
commerce il vous en offre un que vous
pourrez toujours ressortir le jour de
noël maintenant comme ça
mais dites moi oui oui oui oui oui oui
oui oui oui oh vous trouvez ça drôle si
vous n'êtes pas sages vous en offre un
le même